haha the Joe Rogan experience here I
don't want to die tomorrow today not
even five years from now not ten hell if
given the chance I would [ __ ] live a
thousand years if I could because I
think that this world is so [ __ ]
amazing that there is there I don't
think I could learn all the languages
eat all the foods even the ones I don't
like see all the mountains all the
architecture meet all the people all the
cultures all the [ __ ] everything that
exists in this just glorious [ __ ]
amazing place I don't know that I feel
sad that my life can't go on long enough
to know these things and but I've lived
such a life to this point there are
things that mmm 10-year old me would
just have just [ __ ] had a aneurysm
thinking that this was ever gonna be the
way his life turned out considering what
an and outcasted you know pushed aside
bullied [ __ ] with you know really sort
of twisted up confused young lad and
getting to where I am now and I can
leave this place and die and my life has
been oh [ __ ] great
I've lived I I live because I want to
experience things I want to create more
I want to do more with my life but my
life has been great enough it's been
great I've had all the things that I
need that are success that's real
success yes that's real success is hard
to find it is very hard to find but
getting through the all the adversity
and coming out on the other end better
for it yeah I'm more concerned like in
an instant in a way way I want to die
right hmm I think more about that you
know or like the Stoics how do I want to
die right I want to go to Valhalla I
want to I don't want to die a pathetic
way from living an epic life that's more
of a concern in terms of death but
otherwise no death is there death is
coming deaths alongside me deaths riding
in the car with me everywhere
and that's fine he's a good he's a good
[ __ ] wingman
it's great well there's there's that
energy that comes with death that's that
makes life so exciting if you were
immortal he'd be like playing God mode
in a video game is it's not exciting no
have you ever played god mode in video
games no I [ __ ] have I hate on here
right so I [ __ ] plate doom scared me
as a kid when weird like my friends like
check this [ __ ] out you know I was like
a [ __ ] secret drug deal yeah the
little discs in the library computers
you know just yeah what a freak out um
God played God mode and God knows what
yeah terrible cuz you can't die nope for
people don't know we're talking about
when you play God mode you have
unlimited ammo and you can't die yeah
you can't ruin sliceable yeah it ruins
the game games are thrilling but a video
game where you're playing in god mode is
terrible and the reason why is because
there's no consequence there's no same
thing is life there's no risk if there's
no risk if there's no struggle if
there's no there's no there's no
overcoming and you know it's it's like I
always say like I always say I have this
ayat' concept of human entropy that all
humans without proper suffering and
overcoming to use some just some you
know some generic words obviously from a
nietzsche in perspective you just go to
your lowest state of energy people are
all all things in the universe is
subject to entropy and humans are no
different and so obviously we experience
entropy in that our bodies break down
and obviously we have cellular
degradation and things like that but but
we can we can spiritually degrade and if
we don't have proper overcoming if we
don't have a certain kind of suffering
in our life or our agitation we don't
grow agitations great with agitations
are great yeah and I'm also a big fan of
Heidegger so like being towards death
knowing that this is inescapable stop
trying to to look for anything to
alleviate the burden of your own death
and the responsibility of your own
creation of an authentic life you cuz at
the end of the day you can do all these
different [ __ ] things you can change
your mind
you can you can become a this kind of an
[ __ ] ideological premier communist or
you're all tried or you're this you're
that you can create all these little
things you can be a Christian or
Catholic or whatever right you can you
can if you're using these things to
replace your your ownership of
authenticity and the carrying the burden
of your own being in the world then
eventually regardless of all this [ __ ]
that you do when you're laying in bed at
night and you're looking up with that
[ __ ] ceiling you know that you're a
[ __ ] fraud and that you're you you
have a flow you've tried to offload
something and can't get rid of yes yes
100% well put I tell people don't ever
seek comfort seek clarity and seek
improvement you're not gonna comfort
sucks you covered comforts great for a
couple of hours you want to chill and
watch a movie but comfort as a lifestyle
is [ __ ]
it's like you're not gonna get any
improvement you need to be tested that
that term agitation is excellent
[Applause]